[Music]
are you telling a fib about what you
watch in your crib a british poll my
favorite kind
found that 52 percent of people lie
about watching popular tv shows in order
to impress others and appear cooler the
most lied about shows were stranger
things game of thrones breaking bad the
crown and shit's creek
some people even lied about seeing my
show their punishment will be to watch
this over and over again
[Music]
more people saw that here than there
thank you i'll take it
i'll take that
desperate plea for applause
now i don't have this problem of lying
to people about what i watch i just
watch endless episodes of the golden
girls completely nude
i just get out of the shower and sit on
the remote
sounded better when i wrote it
but it just goes to show most people are
desperate to be accepted and not just
cat you can binch watch her on the real
housewives with fake hair
i am a real housewife
with fake hair yeah all right or maybe
some people are sick of others badgering
them to watch certain shows which is
understandable
[Music]
hey jones i forget that uh game of
thrones meme i sent you
deleted it i told you i never watched
game of thrones what you've never seen
game of thrones that's like saying you
never watch downtown abbey or breaking
bad or stranger things or westworld or
gossip girls or veronica mars for the
love of god veronica mars joe like i've
told you a million times i didn't watch
any of that garbage either i'm very
selective and i only watch tv that i
consider to be a work of art the creme
de la creme
now if you'll excuse me
he has that effect
tyrus
why why okay there are two there's two
instincts here there's the per the
person that has to have you watch these
series you mean you haven't watched the
queen's gamut where's the king's gamut i
i so i watch it it's terrible what does
it matter and then the other thing is
why do we lie
well usually because we don't like the
person who's asking us so we just said
yeah i saw it it sucked
they move on but you know what for you
and me it's a little different because
we are select movie critics of the
highest order that is true and our we we
discuss just everything it's way over
your head i won't even i won't even bore
you with the intellect that goes on and
it doesn't bother us that the other
people in our household go what the hell
are you watching and leave the room no
one asks us
to watch something because we will watch
it and then judge you as a person how
you recommended it there was that poor
uh little sound guy we'll call him dion
yes yeah he tried to join our movie
group and he said hey check out this
thing about models and i didn't even see
it but gutfeld sent me an email
immediately saying this was horrible yes
yes and i just went with it and together
we destroyed him as a person how dare
you that movie was terrible it was the
worst movie i've ever seen and he asked
me tyrus which part did you watch all of
it and i was offended right greg and
then greg told him the rest that's how
we roll exactly exactly
uh
mackie do you would you lie about this
sort of thing
okay greg get real
i don't have to lie to impress people
okay
in fact recently a beautiful lady
approached me and said have you ever
watched game of thrones
and i said no i don't care about it
that was when i seduced her
that's how i impress people greg i lie
about seducing women
it worked
i was on the edge of my seat
oh that one
that one took me for a ride
i don't know where i was going but so
there really was no girl no no no
nothing nothing ever happened and i'm a
terrible liar that's why when people
were like did you watch that show i'm
like oh the save by the bell were where
kelly was pregnant
wait kelly was pregnant no i never i
didn't watch he got me again
[Laughter]
i get overwhelmed cat when i turn on uh
when i go to netflix if there's just too
many options and when you by the time
i've gone through 20 of them i no longer
want to watch anything it's like 45
minutes i spend clicking on crap and i
realize we don't we have more variety
but we have no quality
right no quality probably yeah i love
the stuff that sucks you do yeah what
are you watching
yeah no that one's good but like there's
no pregnant teens in that you know what
i mean yeah
yeah you gotta have a pregnant team
murray county i'm telling you we got
them all they live right there all right
cool i'll move on yeah daycare's in the
high school man that's cool awesome no
teen mom like teen mom 2
teen mom young in practice
do they have a tour like the teen moms
come back in their 20s and like give
advice oh they still do like the teen
moms have been filming some of the teen
moms for a very long time and they're
all rich now because they've been teen
moms for so long and it's boring but i
still watch it um so i don't lie to
impress people no i do lie sometimes i
do sometimes i'll do like yeah babe i
already saw it so that what follows is
not let's watch this together oh that's
good since you haven't seen it yeah babe
saw it
then you can turn on the teen moms again
like you really wanted it's really weird
to watch a movie that you've seen with
someone who hasn't watched it and you
start to get irritated
yeah you got to watch movies alone
not to be rude but isn't teen mom's
three grandma no
they are like when they get to their 30s
they're already grandmothers like 30
something yeah 30 something grandmas
there's oh there is some you know baby
daddy drama so on so but it's not yeah
because some of them have like three
people there's one there's a dude out
there that has multiple teen mom baby
mamas it's not me yes
i want to get your
opinion on this story uh do you have uh
do you lie about what you watch i do not
lie about what i watch for the most part
depends on the question but in this
context no i do not lie about what i
watch
but what i will do and i've learned this
workaround is i'll watch the first two
episodes of every show that it becomes
popular because by then you've met all
the cast and you pretty much know the
plot like breaking bad i did it
yellowstone i did it please don't
mention yellowstone this week is a bad
week i i i hear it's a terrible show i i
mean i was in love with it too but
there's just a lot of murdering shooting
up yeah it's like sons of anarchy on
horseback
i hate i love breaking bad kevin costner
is a saint so i like kevin coster i
haven't talked to him in a while i got
to get back to him
he still hasn't he still has my
sweatshirt
now you said mailman right there yeah
waterworld mailman yeah that's yeah
exactly on spec by the way no the only
thing i stream the only thing i stream
or shows about streams
you know about streaming shows there's
this uh fox nation
everybody should check it out what's it
called fox nation oh yes do you have a
show on there a couple yeah
you can watch you can watch me and my
celebrity friends kill animals uh on fox
nation outdoors and we eat them too the
best streaming i'm gonna be sincere the
best show to stream is like old episode
well they're only old episodes of
colombo but when you get into a colombo
groove there's no way out
the plot everything is the same but you
get to see people like william shatner
or jack cassidy you know you have these
great same things i like columbo and
there's not even tina if you're going to
bring like it's got to be matlock then
right anything i'm not a matlock oh come
on murder she wrote
stop it somebody said murder she wrote i
did i like angela lansbury uh you're a
pervert
you are calling someone a pervert
you have a capital p tattooed on your
chest for perverts
i wanted to be a superhero pervert
all right hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else